I've been pretty busy met a girl at Soho
House was she your waitress yes then I
met a girl at Mastro's was she also your
waitress yes then I met a girl at PF
Changs
let me guess she was your hooker yes but
what she really wants to do is wait
tables so I'm sending the first draft of
the book to pinkie this afternoon what
it's done not yet almost I'm excited for
you to read it but I'm also cripplingly
nervous I actually kind of feel like
throwing up but I can't throw up because
I haven't had anything to eat because
it's mine you won't let me in my own
kitchen cast and crew only listen if
reading a book you wrote is anywhere
near as great as it is to actually spend
time with you I'm sure it's gonna be
wonderful
having said that what do I know about
books I'm just a dumb actor I'm here
with Holly Wu darling Naomi Watts tell
me what attracted you to the role of
Diane I just keep getting pigeon-holed
as these complex characters and highly
acclaimed movies for once I would just
love to phone it in and play a
2-dimensional girl in a rom-com with no
inner life of her own ha ha you said
words now is it true you stay in
character between takes oh we all do the
director insists upon it he even has
everyone calling me Diane to help me get
in the headspace Diane looking good um
thanks no not you I was talking to Diane
oh thank you
now where's my peanut butter right over
here cute no I'm looking for peanut
butter
oh you mean Bhoja if I wanted Bojack I
would call Bojack did someone call for
Beauchamp it really cuts down on
confusion
Aloha Kemosabe hey allow me to put on my
producer hat and produce you just for
one second here I have a few notes on
how you're playing me let's see here we
go I find it really troubling that my
movie self is wearing a crew neck
t-shirt easy the problem I do not I just
think if we're telling the story we
should tell it how it really happened
this whole story isn't how it really
happened right because of the shirts
because I'm the one who stole the D I'm
the real hero here my life is full of
exciting adventures I should write a
book oh wait I did hey you're in a mood
perhaps the tightness of that crewneck
is cutting off circulation to the brain
let me talk to Donna in wardrobe
[Music]